il n'y a pas grand monde annoncée dans
l'allocation des marées très bien et oui
je comprends la semaine dernière il
avait déjà doucereux times
évidemment très bon direct ou ce
fauteuil sur 2500 bref c'est pas le
diable elle a annoncé par games est en
phase de test dans des postes importants
comme est un bon départ puis j'ai parce
que j'ai passé d'un coup d'un seul coup
ça s'est arrêté
oui on remarquer non gens de deux gars
là c'est pas tellement la location qui
compte c'est le bureau oui c'est vrai ma
faim on n'a pas fait de nouveau non plus
non mais ça c'est la grêle ya pas eu de
grève non mais là la météo on avait
annoncé l'arrêt annoncé de la grêle ben
alors les gens n'ont pas voulu se
risquer oui il faut bien dire que de
toute manière cette période de l'année
c'est pas une bonne période la seconde
quinzaine de février qu'on le veuille ou
non a toujours été mes sens abriel et
niang enfin les gens parlaient avec le
directeur général et je dise on aurait
dû faire ce qu'elle a beaucoup plus tôt
dans le mois
oshkosh remparts sombres pensées vous
non parce que début février c'est pas
bon non plus et tout le monde est aux
sports d'hiver
oui moi enfin pas tout le monde au moins
cent mille personnes abonnées les autres
avec les autres et paient leurs tiers
provisionnel oui alors évidemment il
aurait fallu faire ça leur paraît molle
saint-janvier nos pensées vous entre le
terme et le tiers de ma mauvaise et la
première quinzaine alors entre les
facultés qui comprend pas non plus non
écoutez je vais vous dire masque qui a
été astucieusement versa juste avant
noël
juste avant noël oui c'est pas bon c'est
ça mon sorte pas avant noël
oui elle est carrément à noël aba'a noël
c'est pas bon non plus octroyer mange il
manquerait oui et après noël après noël
ils sont au lit malades
d'ailleurs beaucoup les fêtes c'est
pareil il doit même chose qui pourrait
bien qu'il ait fait que les environs
c'est pareil là le mardi gras à la
veille du mardi gras et prépare la pop
le jour où ils mangent les crêtes le
lendemain ils ont une indigestion crise
est inverse
mais je pensais quand même que l'automne
les feuilles dans l'ensemble était
meilleure
les spectacles bien si ça dépend où
savez ça si vous êtes indépendant ça ne
dépendra pas chaud ça dépend ça dépendra
récolte du blé ça dépend dire mais ça
dépend de l'humeur des gens rient il
fait passer froid pour s'enfermer dans
un terrain puis là l'autre côté il fait
plus assez chaud pour sortir de chez soi
à l'origine les gens viennent pas oui
novembre c'est un bon vent peut ne pas
être mauvais mais cette année cette
année il a été désastreux il a été
désastreux à cause des sélections
comprenait deux tours d'élections
législatives
sa pompe du monde déjà sa femme enfin
n'exagérons la santé quand même que deux
jours sur trois un bonnet faut pas
calculer comme ça n'en faut pas calculer
comme ça parce que les gens ils pensent
huit jours avant oui on savoir comment
ils vont voter oui et puis jouera pas
pour savoir s'ils ont eu raison de voter
comme ça ça fait déjà quinze jours s'il
ya ballottage ont multiplié par deux
vous avez votre moi qui s'écroula oui je
parle points en octobre bien entendu
parce qu'octobre c'est la rentrée des
classes seul terme
vous aimez l'ouverture de la chasse à
l'homme est ce que vous allez la
fermeture de la pêche mais voilà vous
rendez compte d'ailleurs c'est toujours
le désert dans les salles c'est bien
connu
et bah après octobre oui après octobre
mon vieux vous abordez les mois d'été à
septembre on sera bien loin des 12
places et croyez moi oui septembre voici
avant guerre avant le 15 septembre était
un bon mois pour le faire
et puis il fait trop beau maintenant
alors c'est plus ça va ya plus de saison
c'est ça c'est ça qui nous tue alors
vous avez bon alors vous voyez vous avez
septembre ou juillet juin vous avez
quatre mois qu'ils sont biffés on parle
pas quand je vais à quand-même suisse
trop vous croyez moi je crois pas mais
on jouait pas avec les bals de rues les
balles d'une rue d'ham le 14 juin le 14
juin la fête nationale c'est vrai mais
j'ai pensé plus elle s'est toutefois il
pense et on nous a caché sa joie c'est
pas bon après moi mais vous avez le mois
de mai ben on tombe dans le mois des
anniversaires l'anniversaire du travail
de l'attention de l'armistice dans ma
belle soeur
oui alors eh ben oui à leur égard est
plus près il reste quoi avril alors il
reste à brive mais avril c'est pas bon
non plus pourquoi ah oui c'est pas moi
non plus je vous dire parce qu'ils sont
les premiers beaux jours vous savez ça
maintenant alors dès qu'on aborde
marcillac boris a dû se taire parce que
les gens partent en week-end rick parry
pour les week end du vendredi au lundi
sont à la campagne pas se faire
d'illusions alors vous savez déjà
automatiquement quelques jours qui tombe
ya le jeudi je compte pas le jeudi c'est
une journée en poche complet jeudi il
reste quoi le mardi et le mercredi
oui ma femme mardi et mercredi les gens
sortent quand même année il regarde la
télévision parfois ceux qui n'ont pas la
télévision ils vont chez ceux qui l'ont
ça la télévision fait normes et mentor
au mois d'avril
oui alors il reste quoi il reste le mois
de mars
fribourg qui sortent pas en mars
pourquoi à cause des événements quels
événements baisse coach et moi pourquoi
est ce qu'il y aurait pas d'événements
au mois de mars
il ya toujours des événements au mois de
mars s'est jamais j'ai jamais vu un mois
de mars en événements oui c'est vrai
alors écoutez alors je ne vois pas
l'heure il faut retomber alors tombé en
février à bahia février il ya févry
mailing 18 août alors que ça n'était pas
une bonne date c'est les trois premières
semaines effectivement ne sont pas
bonnes
oui la quatrième aile williams est
épatante je parle pas bien sûr les 26 27
et 28 qui sont tout à fait sûr mars
alors ça c'est mauvais ça ce n'est pas
bon mais bribes alors dites moi alors à
votre avis quelle est la date idéale
c'est ça le 24 24 février
mais pourquoi parce que c'est la veille
du 25 et alors les gens sont contents
ils sortent à habas oui c'est vrai ça
baigne dans c'est pas de chance à un
jour près ont refusé du monde
c'est terrible